how can I just say this more clearly
show us the report show us the report
and I was interesting to see him one of
the as we frequently reference
he'll rags that that Muller has said and
I don't know if this is true just was
the headline that the grand juries are
still continuing their work but it's you
know it's no nice for us to have this
discussion we have to see the facts we
have to see what the report is and we do
not need an attorney general whose job
interview was that the president is
above the law that doesn't think a
president can be indicted to be our
interpreter of something that he should
just show us and again I made my
statement on it we are focused on
meeting the needs of the American people
in their lives and that is not what the
the administration is doing and you
would think the Justice Department would
be busy vetting the report so it could
more quickly bring it to the public in
public view instead what do they do
they're going to court to overturn every
single provision of the Affordable Care
Act not a good use of their time we'll
see them in court